Bentornato a Quantum Computing in Practice. Questo è l'episodio 6. Oggi ci concentreremo su una delle mie
applicazioni preferite dei computer quantistici: simulare la natura. In questo episodio, discuteremo i passaggi necessari
per farlo per qualsiasi tipo di problema di dinamica quantistica, ovvero il problema di trovare come la descrizione di un
sistema quantistico cambia nel tempo. Lo faremo prima ad alto livello e poi esamineremo un esempio specifico
in dettaglio, ovvero l'esperimento IBM del 2023 che ha dimostrato l'utilità quantistica. Per una rapida motivazione
iniziale, una delle storie più famose che noi del campo del quantum computing raccontiamo ancora e ancora:
la storia di Richard Feynman che tenne una conferenza al Caltech nel 1959 e sostanzialmente
fornì motivazione all'intero campo per decenni a venire. Il discorso si chiamava "C'è ancora molto spazio in fondo".
Un titolo divertente, ma l'idea di base era che stava sostenendo che c'era ancora tanta fisica ricca da
scoprire a livello microscopico.
Ora, quel discorso specifico non ricevette molta attenzione fino agli anni '80, quando la tecnologia si era sviluppata notevolmente. E Feynman
chiarì e raffinò anche il suo messaggio nel tempo. Tornò al Caltech negli anni '80 e presentò un altro articolo intitolato
"Simulare la natura con i computer", dove disse specificamente che voleva parlare della possibilità che ci sia
una simulazione esatta, che il computer faccia esattamente la stessa cosa della natura.
essenzialmente essere in grado di eliminare le approssimazioni grossolane di ciò che accade alla scala atomica e sostituirle con
computer che comprendono e sfruttano la fisica quantistica per non solo simulare ciò che fa la natura, ma emularla.
Ora, ricorda questa grafica della linea temporale che ho mostrato in un episodio precedente. A un'estremità, avevamo problemi facili da
risolvere che non richiederanno alcun tipo di accelerazione che il quantistico potrebbe offrire. Ma all'altra estremità, abbiamo problemi
molto difficili che richiedono macchine quantistiche fault tolerant che non abbiamo ancora.
Per fortuna, crediamo che ci siano parecchi problemi di simulazione che si trovano qui nel mezzo, che è la regione in cui
possiamo attualmente lavorare. E ci sono molte ragioni per essere entusiasti e incuriositi da questa prospettiva perché la
simulazione della natura è la base di molte aree applicative interessanti. Solo per citarne alcune: se potessimo meglio
simulare la natura, potremmo accelerare la scoperta di nuovi materiali, creare farmaci e medicine migliori, oppure
esplorare nuova fisica alla base della fisica delle particelle o della cosmologia. Ma prima che tu, io o chiunque altro possa tentare di
applicare il quantum computing a queste aree entusiasmanti, per ora, dovranno comprendere i passi di base in un
tipico flusso di lavoro basato sulla simulazione.
Prima di tutto, vorrai identificare un sistema quantistico di interesse. Questo ti informerà sull'Hamiltoniano che governa la sua evoluzione temporale
e su una descrizione significativa delle sue proprietà iniziali o del suo stato.
Quindi dovrai trovare un metodo appropriato per implementare l'evoluzione temporale di questo stato. Con questi ingredienti
sistemati, i passi successivi coinvolgono l'esecuzione dell'esperimento vero e proprio.
Questi in genere comportano l'ottimizzazione dell'implementazione del quantum circuit dell'algoritmo di evoluzione temporale, l'esecuzione del
circuit o dei circuit sull'hardware quantistico e il post-processing dei risultati. Quindi
possiamo nominare i passi di base coinvolti in un esperimento di simulazione come segue.
Identificazione dell'Hamiltoniano del sistema, codifica dell'Hamiltoniano, preparazione dello stato, evoluzione dello stato,
ottimizzazione del circuit, esecuzione del circuit e post-processing.
Ma questi sono passi abbastanza dettagliati. Ricorda che le quattro fasi del framework Qiskit patterns, che ci aiuta
a capire come implementare una routine in Qiskit, sono: mapping, ottimizzazione del circuit, esecuzione del circuit e
post-processing. Quindi questi quattro primi passi qui sono tutti inclusi sotto l'ombrello del mapping, ed è per questo
che abbiamo dedicato un intero episodio a questa prima fase e se ti sei perso qualcosa ti prego di tornare indietro a guardare l'episodio precedente.
Ora vediamo prima cosa significano questi passi prima di immergerci nel codice. Quindi la prima cosa di base che dobbiamo
fare per eseguire un esperimento di simulazione è identificare l'Hamiltoniano che descrive il sistema. A volte, spesso,
questi sono ben noti, altre volte dobbiamo costruirlo a partire dalla comprensione dei contributi energetici
dei piccoli sottoinsiemi del sistema completo, dove hi è l'Hamiltoniano che agisce su uno degli n sottosistemi di h.
Dovremo anche notare se il sistema è composto da fermioni o bosoni se abbiamo a che fare con particelle elementari. Poi,
dobbiamo codificare l'Hamiltoniano e tradurlo in termini che i computer quantistici possono comprendere. Spesso,
questi Hamiltoniani saranno composti da particelle elementari o sistemi di spin. Se stessimo simulando fermioni o bosoni,
dovremmo scegliere una trasformazione di codifica come la Jordan-Wigner o la Bravyi-Kitaev. Queste trasformazioni ci
diranno come tradurre la definizione dell'Hamiltoniano scritta in termini dei componenti originali, i fermioni o
i bosoni, in operatori di Pauli che vengono facilmente convertiti in gate su un computer quantistico. Ad esempio, la
trasformazione di Jordan-Wigner definita qui fornisce una mappatura dagli operatori fermionici agli operatori di Pauli. Se stiamo già lavorando
con sistemi di spin 1/2 che sono molto comuni, allora possiamo procedere a parte da eventuali coefficienti di normalizzazione
e non abbiamo bisogno di usare uno schema di codifica. Avendo codificato l'Hamiltoniano desiderato nel gate set
del computer quantistico, il passo cruciale successivo è determinare lo stato quantistico iniziale appropriato da cui iniziare la nostra
simulazione. Questo stato dovrebbe idealmente riflettere un significato fisico o una configurazione del
sistema in studio. Ad esempio, se siamo interessati a esplorare l'energia dello stato fondamentale di una molecola, potremmo
iniziare con un'approssimazione di Hartree-Fock o un'altra facilmente preparabile che abbia una sovrapposizione significativa con il vero
stato fondamentale. La scelta dello stato fondamentale iniziale influisce non solo sulla convergenza degli algoritmi variazionali
come VQE, il variational quantum eigensolver, ma anche sull'accuratezza e l'efficienza
dell'evoluzione temporale o del campionamento nella stima di fase quantistica. In sostanza, lo stato iniziale serve come
punto di lancio per il calcolo, preparando il terreno per estrarre osservabili utili sul sistema quantistico
che stiamo modellando. La preparazione di un arbitrario stato a n qubit dove ci sono gli stati della base computazionale e ai è
WEBVTT
il coefficiente rispettivo di ciascuno stato e la condizione di normalizzazione 2 n meno uno può in generale essere approcciata
inizializzando lo stato con l'operatore o; lo stato iniziale sarebbe lo stato della base standard tutto zero, spesso scritto
così per semplicità. In generale questo richiede un numero esponenziale di gate C-NOT. Spesso siamo
interessati a uno stato iniziale specifico per il sistema e la sua preparazione può essere implementata con una quantità ragionevole
di risorse. Gli stati prodotto, ad esempio, in cui i qubit non sono entangled tra loro, richiedono solo operazioni su singolo
qubit. Ora non abbiamo ancora avuto l'opportunità di parlare della trotterizzazione
anche se alcuni di voi probabilmente la conoscono già. In sostanza, la trotterizzazione è un metodo per calcolare l'esponenziazione di matrici che
utilizza approssimazioni per gestire la natura esponenziale degli operatori non commutativi. Quando due operatori come HA
e HB non commutano, dobbiamo usare un trucco intelligente e applicare alternativamente gli esponenziali corrispondenti di
exp(-i HA) e exp(-i HB) per n volte.
Gli operatori di evoluzione alternati vengono applicati. Non illustrerò la dimostrazione qui, ma condividerò un link
a una bella e semplice dimostrazione di questa affermazione nella descrizione. Ma il messaggio da portare a casa è questo: l'evoluzione temporale è una
parte importante del mapping. La trotterizzazione suddivide un'interazione continua in passi discreti che possono
essere implementati su un computer quantistico. Dopo aver generato il circuit trotterizzato, abbiamo finalmente completato il
passo di mapping. Possiamo ora passare all'ottimizzazione del circuit.
Per farlo, ecco cosa deve essere realizzato. È necessario un layout dei qubit che mappa i qubit virtuali del
tuo circuit su quelli fisici dell'hardware. Questo è necessario perché l'hardware può avere topologie particolari
che limitano l'interazione diretta dei qubit fisici. Mentre l'implementazione di
un quantum circuit spesso presuppone la capacità di qualsiasi qubit di interagire con qualsiasi altro qubit. Poi dobbiamo inserire
gate di swap secondo necessità per instradare le interazioni tra qubit che non sono connessi. Dobbiamo tradurre i
gate nel nostro circuit in istruzioni dell'instruction set architecture o ISA che
possono essere eseguite direttamente sull'hardware. Poi dobbiamo eseguire ottimizzazioni del circuit per minimizzare la
profondità del circuit e il conteggio dei gate. Questo passo può essere eseguito anche sul circuit virtuale, ovvero il circuit in cui i qubit
non sono ancora stati mappati alla topologia di un dispositivo. Ma ricorda che molto di questo viene fatto automaticamente per te in
Qiskit. Vedremo esattamente come nella prossima sezione di questa lezione. Dopo il passo di ottimizzazione, siamo pronti per eseguire
il circuit usando una primitiva. Per la maggior parte degli esperimenti di simulazione, sei interessato a comprendere il cambiamento
di certe proprietà del sistema nel tempo. Quindi è probabile che userai la primitiva estimator perché questa
ti permetterà di misurare i valori di aspettativa degli osservabili corrispondenti a proprietà specifiche. Poi
configureremo le migliori opzioni per l'estimator, che può aggiungere tecniche di soppressione e mitigazione degli errori. Infine, eseguiremo
l'esperimento. L'ultimo passo è il post-processing di tutti i dati. Questo estrae i valori di aspettativa misurati o, se
stai usando il sampler, la distribuzione di probabilità campionata nella base computazionale. Se tutto ciò di cui hai bisogno
sono i valori di aspettativa degli osservabili di interesse, questi possono essere ottenuti direttamente dall'estimator
primitivo sia nei loro valori grezzi che in quelli con mitigazione degli errori. Spesso si utilizzeranno poi i valori di aspettativa misurati
per altri calcoli, per altre quantità di interesse che non richiedono il quantum computing e possono essere
calcolate su un computer classico.
Ora cammineremo attraverso un esempio reale di un articolo molto influente pubblicato da IBM qualche anno fa chiamato
"Evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance". Questo articolo, che abbreviamo affettuosamente come
"utility paper", è diventato un articolo molto influente nel campo del quantum computing quasi immediatamente dalla pubblicazione.
La tesi generale dell'articolo è che un computer quantistico rumoroso ha prodotto risultati accurati o valori di aspettativa
usando 127 qubit e 2.880 gate oltre le capacità del calcolo a forza bruta,
ovvero la simulazione esatta dei quantum circuit eseguiti dall'hardware. Questo lavoro fu
importante anche perché mostrò che un computer quantistico poteva essere usato per verificare o confrontare i risultati con altri
metodi classici approssimati per simulazioni quantistiche, come gli algoritmi di reti tensoriali, dove la soluzione
non era nota a priori. Ciò che è anche piuttosto interessante è che ora altri che usano i sistemi IBM Quantum
nel cloud e Qiskit possono duplicare e verificare questi risultati da soli.
Ti mostrerò come fare esattamente questo. Quindi per questo esempio, saremo un po' più specifici riguardo ai
passi coinvolti nel mapping di questo problema in input comprensibili da un dispositivo quantistico. In questo caso, simuleremo
la dinamica della magnetizzazione totale di un sistema di spin magnetici a dipolo su un reticolo in
presenza di un campo magnetico esterno. Il sistema può essere descritto da un modello di Ising con un campo magnetico trasverso.
Lo modelliamo con un quantum circuit parametrizzato dove i parametri corrispondono al valore regolabile
dell'interazione spin-spin o z e alla forza del campo magnetico X. Ora,
questa serie si chiama Quantum Computing in Practice. Quindi discuteremo anche le procedure in questo esperimento
che implementeremo per rendere i risultati il più buoni possibile. Quindi poi discuteremo come rimuovere
i qubit difettosi o i qubit con basse fedeltà dei gate o tempi di decoerenza che potrebbero influire drasticamente sui
risultati sperimentali. Questi qubit difettosi possono verificarsi a causa di una cattiva calibrazione precedente
o di sistemi a due livelli che interagiscono con il qubit. Rimuovere alcuni qubit dalla topologia nativa dell'hardware corrisponde a
considerare un sistema su un reticolo descritto dalla topologia risultante. Discuteremo anche la creazione del
quantum circuit parametrizzato che implementa l'evoluzione temporale del sistema tramite trotterizzazione.
A questo scopo, sarà importante identificare gli strati di entanglement che sono una parte critica per la principale tecnica di
mitigazione degli errori che useremo in seguito. Quindi a questo punto voglio assicurarmi che tu, il pubblico, sappia
che puoi seguire tutto quello che sto per discutere nel tutorial collegato qui sotto e sulla piattaforma IBM
WEBVTT
Quantum Learning. In questo tutorial, potresti notare che abbiamo creato una serie di funzioni di supporto
all'inizio del notebook che possiamo richiamare in seguito per semplificarci la vita. Voglio menzionarle
ora, non perché siano parte del processo ufficiale o formale, ma perché questo è spesso ciò che fanno gli sperimentatori
nella vita reale per aiutarli a eseguire questi tipi di esperimenti. Ci mostra anche come stiamo per suddividere ulteriormente il nostro
problema. Le funzioni che definiamo nel notebook sono le seguenti: Remove qubit couplings,
Define qubit couplings, Construct the layer couplings, Construct entangling layers. E infine, define trotterized
circuit. Parliamo ora dei layer couplings, che aiutano a definire come i qubit
interagiscono con i loro vicini durante la simulazione. I nostri dispositivi quantistici usano qualcosa chiamato layout
heavy hexagonal. Uno schema speciale per connettere i qubit. In questo layout, possiamo raggruppare le connessioni, chiamate archi, in tre
insiemi separati dove nessuna coppia di connessioni nello stesso insieme condivide un qubit. Questo è
importante perché su un vero computer quantistico non possiamo eseguire gate a due qubit contemporaneamente se coinvolgono lo
stesso qubit. Ogni qubit può essere coinvolto in un solo gate alla volta. Dividendo
tutte le connessioni in tre strati, possiamo applicare gate a due qubit su tutto il dispositivo in tre
round, assicurandoci che nessun qubit sia usato in più di un gate per strato. Questi
gate implementano l'interazione ZZ del modello di Ising, e vengono ripetuti ad ogni passo della simulazione, chiamato
passo di Trotter. Il twirling modifica il rumore nel dispositivo in modo che anche un modello di rumore semplice
sia probabilmente accurato. Questo rende anche possibile apprendere accuratamente il modello di rumore e usare le informazioni ottenute
nelle tecniche di mitigazione degli errori.
Poi, dobbiamo rimuovere i nostri qubit difettosi dalla nostra lista possibile di qubit fisici che possiamo usare per
l'esperimento. Come ho detto, un qubit può diventare difettoso per una varietà di ragioni diverse. A volte è solo una cattiva
calibrazione, un semplice errore che può essere risolto semplicemente calibrando di nuovo.
A volte è un po' più complicato e legato a qualcosa che chiamiamo TLS, che è un difetto interfacciale a due livelli
che porta a fluttuazioni dei parametri del qubit e rilassamento. Questo può essere
risolto scaldando un po' l'intero sistema e poi raffreddandolo di nuovo. Ma ci vuole un po' di tempo e non è possibile
farlo tramite cloud. Quindi per ora, la cosa più semplice da fare è semplicemente escluderli dalla nostra lista di qubit fisici
possibili che useremo. Puoi identificare facilmente quali qubit non si comportano come previsto dalla piattaforma IBM Quantum.
Puoi tracciare le caratteristiche dei qubit lì nella piattaforma o scaricarle come CSV. Poi crea un elenco di tutti i
qubit che vuoi escludere e rimuovili semplicemente dall'elenco dei qubit fisici totali del dispositivo.
Bene. Ora continuiamo con il nostro passo di mapping generando il nostro circuit trotterizzato. Come abbiamo mostrato
in precedenza, la trotterizzazione discretizza l'evoluzione temporale in una serie di passi e dobbiamo decidere quanti passi.
Ne sceglieremo sei qui. Ma in generale la strategia è bilanciare quello che viene chiamato l'errore di Trotter, che è un
errore di approssimazione algoritmico, con l'errore derivante dalla decoerenza. Più passi di Trotter riducono l'errore di approssimazione
ma richiedono circuit quantistici più profondi che subiscono più rumore da decoerenza. Definiremo il
circuit in termini del parametro theta che è la forza dei layer couplings del campo magnetico esterno e il
numero di passi e qubit e naturalmente il backend del dispositivo. A causa della
dipendenza della magnetizzazione del sistema dalla forza del campo magnetico esterno, è interessante
eseguire la simulazione a vari valori della forza del campo magnetico che si traducono in diversi angoli di RX nella
rotazione per RX nel circuit. Ora, avendo generato il nostro circuit, passiamo alla sua ottimizzazione.
Il primo passo è definire un pass manager. Ricorda che nel contesto del Qiskit SDK, la transpilazione si riferisce al
processo di trasformazione di un circuit in input in una forma adatta per l'esecuzione su un dispositivo quantistico.
La transpilazione avviene tipicamente in una sequenza di passi chiamati transpiler passes. Un pass manager è un oggetto che
memorizza un elenco di transpiler passes e può eseguirli su un circuit. Crea un pass manager inizializzando un
oggetto pass manager con un elenco di transpiler passes. Alla fine, il nostro pass manager
creerà un ISA circuit, un circuit che deve essere scritto in termini dell'instruction set architecture del backend,
che descrive il circuit e i gate nativi del backend ma mancano delle informazioni di temporizzazione necessarie per eseguire il
circuit. Ora siamo pronti per eseguire il nostro circuit, che è il terzo passo dei Qiskit patterns. Come detto prima, useremo
sicuramente l'estimator come nostra primitiva di scelta per questo esperimento poiché vogliamo misurare la
magnetizzazione totale del sistema e stimare il valore di aspettativa degli osservabili è ciò per cui l'estimator è stato
progettato. In questo passo sarà anche cruciale specificare le opzioni per la mitigazione degli errori. Useremo la zero noise
extrapolation per ottenere i migliori risultati possibili. In particolare nel tutorial, vedrai che specifichiamo due o più
valori del fattore di rumore ai quali valutare i modelli estrapolati e specifichiamo
la probabilistic error amplification come nostra opzione di amplificazione. Ora, la probabilistic
error amplification o PEA era davvero il metodo di mitigazione degli errori di scelta qui perché scala molto meglio
delle altre opzioni. Ed è questo ciò che è importante quando si lavora al livello di 100 o più qubit.
Ultimo ma non meno importante, esegui l'esperimento e ci vorrà un po' di tempo per completarsi, ma per ora facciamo riferimento ai dati
accodati e memorizzati dal tutorial. Esamineremo i metadati notando in particolare i gate a strati e
gli strati mitigati poiché stiamo per usarli per rimuovere un mucchio di errori dai nostri dati grezzi. Siamo quasi pronti
a tracciare i nostri risultati finali. Ma prima di farlo, aggiungiamo rapidamente un intermezzo su cosa si intende esattamente per zero
noise extrapolation o ZNE. L'abbiamo trattato brevemente in episodi precedenti, ma per ripassare, la zero noise extrapolation
è una tecnica di mitigazione degli errori che rimuove gli effetti di un rumore sconosciuto durante l'esecuzione del circuit che può essere
scalato in modo noto. Assume che i valori di aspettativa scalino con il rumore mediante una funzione nota mostrata qui dove i
WEBVTT
parametri lambda specificano la forza del rumore e possono essere amplificati. Possiamo implementare ZNE con i seguenti passi.
Prima, amplifica il rumore del circuit per diversi fattori di rumore: lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, e così via. Esegui ogni circuit con rumore amplificato per misurare
il valore di aspettativa A di lambda 1, A di lambda 2, e così via. E poi estrapolando al limite di rumore zero
il valore di aspettativa A di zero.
La sfida principale nell'implementare con successo ZNE è avere un modello accurato per il rumore nel valore di aspettativa
e amplificare il rumore in modo noto.
Ci sono tre modi comuni in cui l'amplificazione degli errori è implementata per ZNE: scalare la durata degli impulsi tramite calibrazione,
ripetere i gate in cicli di identità e aggiungere rumore tramite il campionamento di canali di Pauli.
Chiamiamo quest'ultimo PEA. La probabilistic error amplification è la scelta migliore qui perché lo stretching degli impulsi è
computazionalmente molto costoso. Il gate folding manca di garanzie teoriche nel preservare il bias del rumore. Ma la PEA può essere
applicata a qualsiasi circuit che può essere eseguito con fattori di rumore nativi, ma richiede l'apprendimento del modello di rumore. La PEA assume
lo stesso modello di rumore basato su strati della probabilistic error cancellation.
Tuttavia, evita il sovraccarico di campionamento che scala esponenzialmente con il rumore del circuit. Per apprendere il modello di rumore,
dobbiamo prima identificare gli strati unici di operazioni a due qubit nel circuit.
Per ogni strato, applica il Pauli twirl ai gate a due qubit per assicurarsi che il rumore sia ben descritto da un modello di rumore di damping.
Ripeti coppie identità di strati a profondità variabile e infine adatta una fedeltà o un errore per ogni canale di rumore. E
naturalmente, mentre raccomando di comprendere questo metodo fino a un certo punto, farlo a mano in Qiskit è
molto più semplice come mostrato nel tutorial. Ora, finalmente, diamo un'occhiata ai dati tracciati. La linea
grigia tratteggiata mostra i risultati esatti ottenuti con metodi classici approssimati con un errore di approssimazione
convergente a una soglia bassa. Come puoi vedere, i dati grezzi per i diversi fattori di rumore che abbiamo scelto all'
inizio si discostano notevolmente da questa linea tratteggiata. La linea blu continua mostra i dati tenendo conto del nostro
processing ZNE. E puoi vedere immediatamente che è molto più vicina ai risultati esatti.
In sintesi, i valori rumorosi mostrano un'alta deviazione dai valori esatti. I
valori mitigati sono vicini ai valori esatti, dimostrando l'utilità della tecnica di mitigazione basata su PEA.
E questo conclude essenzialmente questo episodio. Per riassumere brevemente ciò che abbiamo imparato, la simulazione quantistica è una
delle aree di applicazione più promettenti nel breve-medio termine.
Ha applicazioni ampie, dai farmaceutici alla fisica delle alte energie,
alla scienza dei materiali e altro ancora. L'utility paper di IBM pubblicato nel 2023 ha indicato
la via verso la possibilità di usare i computer quantistici per la scoperta scientifica. E abbiamo lavorato attraverso il
tutorial associato a quell'articolo in profondità. I passi per affrontare un problema di simulazione dall'inizio
alla fine sono relativamente semplici, specialmente una volta che ci si fa la mano. E la mia speranza è che tu
possa d'ora in poi usare questo video e il tutorial come guida per altri problemi di simulazione in futuro.
Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta su Quantum Computing in Practice.